Speaker 1: Let's go to our audience and hear
from some of you. Such an important week. COVID
recovery of mine, the Herschel Walker loss in
Georgia and so many important things. I want to
hear from you. We take calls via discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
And we are going to start today with Chuck from
Pennsylvania. Chuck, what is on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Can you hear.
Speaker 1: Me,
David? I can. Loud and clear, my friend.
Speaker 2: All right, cool. Yeah. I just want
to say how I. My faith in humanity or the U.S. has
been slightly restored with the the Walker loss.
Speaker 1: Has it really, though, because he
almost won? You know what I mean? It's like I
get I'm with you in the sense that if we imagine
an America today with Senator elect Herschel
Walker and then we say, oh, we avoided that, of
course, that that that's good. But the guy almost
won. Like, that's extraordinarily depressing.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah. I mean, like you said,
it's depressing at the same time
because I don't know how many,
how like, he got like 2 million votes and
and he only won by, like, what was it,
48, 51% split or something like that. So. But
anyway, so yeah. Slightly but still depressing.
But now it's sort of like a food for thought or
just like something that I've thought about. Like,
so, you know, like the right there, there
against all of the electric car, like any
push for green energy, stuff like that. Yeah.
They want to stick in their traditional ways.
So I've thought about like in, you know,
5000 years. How many years? I don't know.
But do you see maybe like the Republican Party
becoming like the sort of like a small group,
almost like the Amish, where they're kind of just
shunned because they're stuck in their ways and.
Speaker 1: Like total technological
Luddites or something.
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah, yeah. Like, just
they're still using their diesel trucks
and using coal burning coal for energy
in their small, little community. And
they're stuck in their religious ways.
Speaker 1: Listen, it's not impossible
because think about it. You know, they're
against all sorts of medical research that
certainly is going to lead to advancements. And
it's totally plausible that they will sort of
shun taking availing themselves of some of that.
We're seeing it with vaccines already right there
of we see this huge anti-vaxx movement. So
they're already self-selecting selecting out
there. They seem to love just burning gasoline
in their vehicles for for whatever reason,
and they consider it manly and culturally relevant
and whatever else. So maybe they will resist that
as well. The way I think it might happen is at a
certain point it seems the direction things are
going is that new vehicles sold will have to be
electric. But like if you can keep an existing,
if you can keep an existing ice vehicle on
the road, then you can keep driving it or
something. So it it might become kind of
like how in Cuba, because of the embargo,
a lot of the cars are really, really old,
the American cars. And they just have to keep
maintaining them because that's what they have.
It might end up being something sort of like that.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah. I mean, you know,
they may end up being forced with like the
car thing because once they get older, you
know, there won't be parts for the old ices
and they'll all be electric or something like
that. But I mean, even just as far as like you
were saying with like medicine and stuff,
like I know like the Amish communities now,
like they don't go to regular dentists and stuff
like some of them. So like they all end up like
their teeth right out and stuff. So I don't know,
it was just something I kind of thought kind of
like a it's I see similarities sort of thing.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I absolutely do. And I don't
think it would listen to become like
the Amish. It's going to take them much,
much, much longer time. Yeah, but the
idea of it, I completely understand.
Speaker 2: Yeah. That was all I had, though.
Speaker 1: All right, Chuck from Pittsburgh,
thank you. Mm hmm. Very powerful phone call. I
appreciate it. Just as a reminder, if you want to
get on to talk to me in the discord, your nickname
has to be your name and where you're calling from
or where you're calling from and your name. All
of the different nicknames that are in there, you
are self-selecting out because it's just not the
right format. Very, very important to understand